bienvenidos a en 5 minutos donde
intentamos explicar de manera sencilla
asuntos complicados la anulación de la
histórica sentencia roe versus wade
modificó drásticamente el derecho al
aborto en eeuu que es el fallo roe
versus weight qué consecuencias tiene la
supresión de este derecho para las
mujeres y cómo se llegó a este retroceso
en
1969 una joven norma mccorvey conocida
por el seudónimo de jane road quedó
embarazada alegando que había sido
violada llevó en su caso los tribunales
en contra del entonces fiscal del
distrito henry white para pedir el
derecho a abortar sin embargo en texas
donde vivía el aborto era ilegal a menos
de que la madre estuviera en peligro
tras el fallo negativo de un tribunal
federal tuvo que dar a luz pero su
defensa llevó el caso hasta la corte
suprema que en 1973 consideró con siete
votos contra dos que el gobierno no
podía regular los abortos entonces el
alto tribunal determinó que las mujeres
tenían derecho a poner fin a su embarazo
y que éste estaba sujeto a la libertad
de elección personal
protegido en la constitución del país
así se sentó un precedente histórico en
el que el aborto paso a ser un derecho
constitucional de las mujeres en eeuu
hasta la semana 23 del embarazo pero
tras casi 50 años el pasado 24 de junio
la corte suprema anuló robert sus webs
al considerar que el aborto no es un
derecho constitucional qué cambios trae
su anulación el hecho de que ya no sea
considerado un derecho constitucional
significa que ya no rige en todo el país
por lo tanto la regulación del aborto
pasa a ser decisión de cada uno de los
50 estados y queda en manos de las
orientaciones políticas de cada
territorio con el partido republicano
defendiendo la prohibición del aborto y
los demócratas el derecho a abortar
nueve estados prohibieron el aborto poco
después de conocer el fallo que revertía
roe versus wait misurí alabama arkansas
kentucky louisiana oklahoma dakota del
sur y utah y wisconsin y en total 26
estados entre los cuales texas han
prohibido ya o aprobaran restricciones
totales o casi totales
16 de estados tienen leyes que refuerzan
la protección del derecho al aborto
aproximadamente 36 millones de mujeres
perderían ese derecho en todo el país la
rigidez de la regulación dependerá
también de cada estado mientras en
algunos se contemplan algunas causales
en otros como en ohio el aborto estará
prohibido incluso en casos de violación
los activistas por los derechos de las
mujeres temen un aumento de las muertes
de madres gestantes ya que muchas se
verán forzadas a acudir a abortos
clandestinos en condiciones extremas y
lejos de ser salud les temen también un
aumento de las condenas incluso con
penas de cárcel para las mujeres que se
sometan a abortos igual que para el
personal médico que practique los
procedimientos en algunos estados como
en texas los médicos podrían afrontar
hasta cadena perpetua la decisión de la
corte afecta especialmente a las mujeres
más pobres ya que muchas mujeres tendrán
que viajar en miles de kilómetros a
otros estados para recurrir a un aborto
algo que cuesta tiempo y dinero y no
todos lo tienen se teme también una casa
de brujas contra mujeres que tengan
abortos espontáneos y que éstas se vean
sometidas a investigaciones para
determinar si el aborto fue o no
provocado
además hay alertas de que habrá un
aumento del número de niños dados en
adopción tras embarazos no deseados o de
madres adolescentes o que no puedan
hacerse cargo de sus hijos cómo se llegó
a esta histórica derogación en las
últimas décadas el derecho al aborto en
eeuu ha estado completamente politizado
incluso presidentes como ronald reagan
hicieron su campaña con la promesa de
prohibir el aborto y el también
republicano donald trump hizo de esta
consigna uno de sus caballos de batalla
en su administración de hecho durante su
mandato trump designó a tres de los
nueve magistrados de la corte suprema
configurando así una mayoría de seis
jueces conservadores en el alto tribunal
de los cinco jueces que votaron por
revocar roe versus wait 3 fueron los
designados por donald trump
al ser vitalicios estos nombramientos
hasta que los jueces no se retiran o
fallezcan mantendrán su puesto por lo
que no se prevén cambios cercanos a la
inclinación de la corte suprema ni
tampoco que ésta dé marcha atrás a su
reciente decisión sobre el aborto
incluso con su postura conservadora
otros derechos como el matrimonio
igualitario o el uso de anticonceptivos
podrían verse afectados negativamente
otra opción para reincorporar el derecho
al aborto en el país sería que el
congreso legislará a nivel nacional pero
esta vía también es poco probable ya que
esta ley debería pasar por el senado
donde los demócratas están lejos de
conseguir los 60 votos necesarios para
lograrlo si le sirvió el vídeo para
entender los desafíos que plantea la
nueva sentencia sobre el aborto en eeuu
los esperamos en otro episodio de cinco
minutos en france 24 y france24 puntocom